[Music]  Bob Dylan did an ad for Chrysler cars  and everyone's talking about it today  apparently the ad they aired was the  much shorter version of the original  Dylan ad here's the part they edited out  for time take a look  is it anything normal American that  America because you can import original  so let Jeremy brew your beer let's  whistle and make your watch let Asia  assemble your phone let France make your  water let Denmark make a cheese let  India answer your tech support  let chilli catch a sea bass let Mexico  make your pinatas there Canada make your  dental floss that Costa Rica so your  cargo shorts that Yemen manufacture your  Chia Pets let Japan produce your  animated torture Core will build your  car parts that are built in Canada or  Mexico  [Applause]